you
if you are a woman and have uterine
fibroids your doctor may recommend
robotic fibroid tumor removal also known
as robotic myomectomy
your reproductive organs include your
vagina
cervix
uterus
fallopian tubes
and ovaries
a uterine fibroid also known as a
leiomyoma is a non cancerous tumor in
your uterus it begins with an abnormal
growth of cells in your uterine wall
uterine fibroids grow in place and don't
spread or metastasize to other parts of
your body
the four main types of uterine fibroids
are
intramural which grows inside the wall
of your uterus
Sub Zero soul which grows on the outer
wall of your uterus
submucosal which grows in the inner wall
of your uterus
and pedunculated which grows on a small
stock attached to the inner or outer
wall of your uterus
the size and location of your uterine
fibroids may cause symptoms such as
heavy menstrual bleeding
your regular bleeding between periods
lower back pain
pain during sex
frequent urination
fullness and enlargement of the lower
abdomen
and pregnancy complications
before your procedure an intravenous
line or IV will be started
you will be given antibiotics through
the IV to decrease your chance of
infection
you will be given general anesthesia to
put you to sleep and block pain during
the procedure
a breathing tube will be inserted
through your mouth and into your airway
to help you breathe during the operation
your surgeon will make a small incision
in or just above your belly button and
insert a tube called a port carbon
dioxide gas will pass through this port
into your abdomen the gas will inflate
your abdomen giving your surgeon more
room to see and move the surgical tools
after your abdomen is inflated a
high-definition camera will be inserted
into this port
your surgeon will make additional port
incisions for robotic instruments as
well as for instruments used by patients
I'd assistance
an assistant will insert all of the
robotic tools through these ports unlike
standard laparoscopic instruments these
tools can rotate 360 degrees and have
more flexibility than the human wrist
seated at a special console your surgeon
will operate the robotic arms and the
camera with joystick like controls and
foot pedals
a computer will translate the exact
movements of your surgeon's fingers into
precise movements of the surgical tools
same time a high-definition vision
system will provide a magnified
three-dimensional stereoscopic view of
the surgical area your surgeon will
locate your uterine fibroid and inject
it with medication to reduce bleeding
next your surgeon will carefully cut
around the edges of your fibroid
and remove it your uterus will not be
removed the remaining edges of your
uterus will be closed with sutures
at the end of your procedure the tiny
incisions will be closed with stitches
staples surgical glue or skin closure
strips
after your procedure your breathing tube
will be removed and you will be taken to
the recovery area for monitoring
you'll be given pain medication as
needed
you may be released from the hospital
the same day or within one day after the
procedure